while comic book movies often put their
own twists on the source material they
usually do draw some inspiration from
the original books take the flash for
instance which is borrowing from 2011's
Flashpoint by Jeff Johns and Andy kubert
so what happens in the flashpoint comic
well similar to the film Barry Allen
zooms back in time and rescues his
mother when he returns to the present
day Nora Allen is still alive but
everything else has fallen apart Bruce
Wayne was shot dead as a child leading
his father to become a more violent Dark
Knight and his mother to become the new
Joker Superman was logged up by
scientists the moments he landed on
earth and the nations of the mascara and
Atlantis are at War obviously there have
been some substantial changes here in
the film Bruce Wayne is very much alive
played in the alternate reality by
Michael Keaton there's no Superman to be
seen but based on the trailer it does
look like Supergirl is filling that role
like her cousin though it appears she's
been imprisoned for quite some time